[Music]
an extreme excuse news oh that was me in
high school dude I didn't use for
everything like an extreme one in
extreme excuse no why are you late Missy
me leg came off that's an extreme one
lithium off my leg came all mad guys
right there I was like you licked them
on the king of magadh
that's not that extreme submitted by
reigning babies it's raining babies hey
hey
it Irish soccer team apologize for
faking a player's death to get out of
play what's going out what's happening
in Ireland right now cuz wasn't there
that judge that this girl got raped and
then he was like his verdicts like oh
the guy's not guilty cuz she was wearing
lacy panties so she obviously wanted and
you hear that one that was huge
let's see panties okay but here's the
problem with this lie there's no out I
know exactly where there's no out to it
that's the dumbest [ __ ] lie ever it's
it's like the you lost your leg being
right so why are you late - uh - my leg
fell off they fell off well how come
your leg is on didn't think it through
why would you even say such an extreme
trend I believe in karma dude yeah like
like like my mom stick or Tyco a secret
[ __ ] like that like I can never say
stuff like that cuz I'm like that shit's
gonna come back someone might actually
get sick or might actually pass away I
should have said terrible liars do I
play with balance of universe I had a
business partner would you guys know of
that [ __ ] said he had a stroke
and his mom was there to pick him up and
get taken to the hospital and because he
didn't want to come to a [ __ ] meeting
cuz he didn't like because we were gonna
confront him about his poor business tax
so he knew he had a se stroke so he said
he had a stroke right any but how scared
you are scary you are no no 30 years of
confrontation what do you just say I
can't make the meeting so coward that he
had a stroke at a liquor store he said
thank God his mom was there to take him
to the hospital so we called his bluff
called the persister ask him if we're
his mom was that his mom was in Chicago
and so okay but those I saw your mom's
in Chicago uh uh yeah you little [ __ ]
how dare you spy on my mind yeah liquor
store a surveillance of it I want
everything so here's like open I did
have a stroke were like cool will show
us the medical like I want to see the
bill and everything else and then won't
will pay for it don't know where to be
found
yeah that's how trash human beings are
dude [ __ ] true guys ever like that
bit like who would lie that big that's
like a seven-year-olds lie yeah that's
pretty crazy
so this soccer team here they lie what
what club the club is battle practice
Nellie Braca FC never heard of them are
they this professional know what leaguer
then so I Ireland lace leycester senior
league I don't know anyway why they lied
they said that one of their players died
in a automobile accident Oh
and so there's life spreads so much to
the point where like oh because they
were trying to avoid so what really
happened was that this player that they
said died he his job transferred him
over to Spain so he could no longer be
in that soccer team oh so they were
scrambling to get a player for the
upcoming match and so the only
reasonable thing we can think they lied
for a league game that makes sense well
cuz they thought since the guy left to
Spain that they would there'd be no one
there to really see him ever again ask
him anything but the fact that it's a
league it's a stupid no just be honest
yeah that's like you know I tree like
are trading on Friday it's kind of like
we're just going there messing around
none of us are trying to be a pro
fighter if I can't make it one day I
just go I'm sick you know I don't gotta
tell David hey I can't come grappling
with you yeah cuz [ __ ] my mom died
can't make it to class cuz my mom died
she got shot in the head
oh I can't grapple I can't learn the
rear naked choke today I'll just say I
can't go dude just say I can't make it
[ __ ] it's like yeah it's like a
bowling team it's a league what's so
wrong for them to say hey our player
moved we need an extra player that's how
about this what you invited me to do
Jitsu class right and I said dude I
can't I'm not a morning person I don't
I'm playing Red Dead Redemption if you
had if you lie like this team does lie
say no to him a big one okay so ask me
to come o Friday we've been grappling
you want to come join us to do jujitsu
this Friday yeah Oh what time uh 911 I
can't why see on my dog Kirby yeah I'm
got run over and his leg is infected
yeah so I'm gonna we have a we have we
have to go to the vet and there's this
expensive medicine so I have to actually
drive to Gilbert cuz I need to borrow
money from my mom Gilbert Arizona yeah
okay that makes sense see you don't you
know what we would have done crowd fun
here is that the tea like the next match
that they had they did a moment of
silence Oh
Fernando Fernando's like what the [ __ ]
I'm still alive
what do you mean the top guys yeah like
you know how there's like the head coach
is like were they the only ones that
that said the slide then it spread or
was it was everyone in on a worse
picture for Fernando yeah yes now I Bo
have no eyes whatsoever he looks like a
drug that's creepy well this is the
moment of silence Oh Mike that's the
soccer team or like the match where they
plan to go like the park down the street
basically it's a league game
you know it's like I kid you not this is
an episode of like the office like
Michael Scott did this lie and then he
has sit there just like holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] the club secretary was the one who
created this lie all God they fired this
person they were like they will no
longer have any footballing duties with
the club but the the player that
supposedly died he did receive a phone
call before this spread saying like hey
just ignore anything that's coming out
saying that you might have had an
accident just ignore it and so he was
like okay but then he found out when
friends started sending him like
newspaper there's newspaper headlines
that's how you find out that you behind
yeah so the secretary did it yeah you
gotta get stick oh my god I love
catching people a lie and just like
holding it and like keep pushing them to
see how far they would keep lying yeah
love that [ __ ] why do you like it
because it's funny to see they try to
cover their tracks I love watching
people smash that's why I love to catch
a predator like the guy that orders the
pizza he acts like like he's cool then
they get more worried they start
sweating yeah and when they come clean
it's not fun anymore the cops and then
you know I look I just really wanted to
see one episode where a guy like is
trying to see like a young boy and then
Chris head and then Chris Hansen comes
out he goes so what are you doing here
who you those well that works too
nothing sucks like a red ball dad I'd be
crazy Chris hands like where they turn
the tables on Chris Hanson yeah no no
they trap like the the Kaiser Hawaii
he's like well people do mine NBC yep
that'd be amazing cuz then that's his
way of saying like you know what he goes
I didn't know you're a young person I
thought I was an adult he's just gonna
[ __ ] is that so I thought you and I were
to [ __ ] he just horny that's what I
would have done
oh then they always have cops there too
yeah I would love it if they came like
strapped and they turn the tables on NBC
and then keep you take them hostage
looks like a stand but they're doing a
great job though what are you guys cops
there too I know but they're catching
predators I know but I just want to see
it just for entertainment oh yeah yeah
yeah for entertainment it's okay
something you know yeah I would never I
oh my god you this is so crazy man
what's the word excuse me you guys ever
ever used to get out of nothing like
ours [ __ ] worse was just like I'm sick
I'm sick I was just gonna say I'm sick I
feel I did feel nauseated yeah that's it
now I'm going to do white lies instead
of just telling people how it is because
sometimes white lights work a little
better right so example fried Four
Weddings it's like so you want to come
to my wedding
no now I do with white lies where I go
I'm probably gonna be busy yeah I do
agree about taking your liar okay I'm
probably gonna bet still a hard no okay
well I'm not good at this [ __ ] okay I
don't know yeah but I'm probably gonna
book something there so listen I used to
get beaten to a bloody pulp for lying
all the time so now I'm not your dad
yeah now I'm so [ __ ] like honest to
the point where it just everything
sounds like it's just a lie now yeah cuz
I tell everything to the T cuz my
brother and I used to get beaten to
death for lying dude so now is just to
the porn online now you just say
everything you just [ __ ] just do
everything now if I get if I get
interrogated you guys are all fun I feel
like you know you ain't gonna rat kill
you first then but I love yes save our
own s Oh cuz your rat look who's all
right cuz I'll ask you something live
then it's just so apparent baby can't
keep secrets like you know like you like
so who stole from the bank and David
won't say anything you bring up like
Express you should have really good lies
cuz you were like growing up under such
extreme like house arrest oh yeah I feel
like I feel like as a kid I probably had
hella lies but there's also a point
where I was like [ __ ] this [ __ ] I just
jumped out a window I'm just gone too so
I don't know I think lying is very
tiring it is it's very tiring it's like
especially when it's like unnecessary
yeah it's like when you make up stories
and [ __ ] and you have to like hold on to
that and like keep on it's it's so
tiring then you gotta remember the
[ __ ] lies it's liberating to tell the
truth I don't want baggage then you're
like you know what yeah there's I
cleared my sinuses treat I told you the
truth and you're gonna like something
like this right like I've done multiple
times before where there is like let's
say a friend wanted to get away from
like his wife for a night right and
there's are some [ __ ] like that right
that she goes oh so where was where was
Jerry I'm like no [ __ ] no no I could
do that I mean obvious to grab you guys
are at the bar yeah stuff like I mean
like that stuff is something I could do
especially for a homie or something like
that right like I'll do that [ __ ] cuz
it's why it's a [ __ ] you know like
hahaha I'll do that
wait I asked you where Bart was huh
gobbling you're grappling you rather
roll around on the ground with him than
me come on now
I like strategic line even while we play
games that can never [ __ ] line that's
when it's fun because no one gets hurt
the difference between a line a
strategic line well I mean when it's a
game and you're strategically like poker
yeah for poker or horror where no one
gets hurt cuz when when you hurt
somebody or you violate trust with
people I think that's when it really
[ __ ] sucks yeah yeah but if it's to
save your life because some [ __ ] went
down just like you know some people you
know they hid Jewish people when the
Nazis came and they lied or whatever
like those kind of things right it's
like for the greater good
I'd do it I'd lied my [ __ ] teeth off
yeah you know
are you harboring fugitives nope
Hans laws we respond well what was the
fugitive exactly
don't you think you sound guilty exactly
and you know what it's never a lie it's
my truth against yours you seen that
move I can't wait to meet your kids you
seen inglorious bastards like that see
ya no Jewish people under my feet under
my shoes yeah yeah you know I respect
that yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]